- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape;
bipedal, naked large-brained. Lone the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Matthias] So, as Ed mentioned, I'm sort
of a biochemist by training and I've been
wondering for many years how it is
possible actually that ancient DNA is
preserved in fossils over tens of
thousands of years. I'm also wondering how
much further can we go in time. How will
it be in 5 or 50 years, perhaps, if I can
still see that if someone giving a talk
here what material are they going to talk
about. Is it a million years? In order to
address the question of how long DNA can
be preserved in bones, I think it's
worthwhile to look a bit into bone
structure. The bone consists of two major
components one is an organic component,
collagen, it's a protein that gives some
level of elasticity to bones so that they
don't break easily; and there's another
very interesting component which makes up
up to 50% of the bone mass which is
hydroxyapatite. It's a form of calcium
phosphate that has a very interesting
biochemical property which is shown in
this experiment here. If you take a
mixture of DNA of different sizes, sort of
similar to what you might find in an
ancient bone, and you dissolve this DNA in
water and you add a suspension of pure
hydroxyapatite, DNA will instantly bind to
the hydroxyapatite. Then, you can wash
that hydroxyapatite part off with water or
with all sorts of low salt buffers and you
will not release this DNA from
hydroxyapatite. It will only come down if
you give it a harsh chemical treatment
such as, using a decalcifier to break up
the hydroxyapatite structure or using a
strong phosphate buffer. You can repeat
this experiment using ancient bone. This
is shown here. The DNA, pool of DNA
fragments, immediately binds to ancient
bone that is also known to contain
endogenous ancient DNA and that is of age
40 to 100,000 years. It only gets, comes
down, after intense treatment with
chemicals. That even works if you have
bones that are much older and bones that
are actually known, at least to current
level of resolution, not to carry any
ancient DNA like this one from a site in
Germany that's 600,000 years old, or this
bone of a dinosaur that's 18 million years
old. While this is sort of a very
interesting proof that you can recover DNA
from dinosaurs, it's not yet proof yet
that this can also be done for authentic
dinosaur DNA. But, an important take home
message here is that the bone structure
itself sort of provides a very good
carrier for DNA and there's basically no
limit in the DNA binding capacity of bone
over time. So, what is it, then, that sort
of limits us in our ability to study
ancient DNA through time? Obviously there
are also other processes taking place that
degrade DNA over time. There are a lot of
reactions: some hydrolytic, some oxidative
reactions, and the most, the ones that are
thought to damage DNA most are those ones
with the red arrow here which is
hydrolysis of purine bases, or the letters
As and Gs coming off the DNA and then over
time your DNA breaks down into shorter and
shorter molecules. You can model this, for
example here, assuming a strain break
every 50 base pairs in your DNA then you
will see that you've very few long
molecules but a lot of very short
molecules. The more you damage your DNA,
the more this distribution gets shifted to
the left end until all your DNA has
disappeared or broken down into fragments
that are too short to make sense of. It's
important to know that these chemical
processes are temperature dependent. They
occur much slower at lower temperature
which is also why if you look for the
world record of, sort of, ancient DNA
genome sequencing you have to go to the
permafrost. Two years ago, I think, there
was a very exciting paper published; an
almost full genome for a 700,000 years old
horse from permafrost. It gets more
complicated if you leave permafrost and if
your fossils are subject to these
temperature cycles that occur during the
Pleistocene. For the last, roughly,
100,000 years temperatures are mostly
colder than they are now then you enter
these interglacials where you have
elevated temperature and these are very
detrimental to DNA preservation.
Nonetheless, sort of being limited to the
last 100,000 years and temperate climate
zones is not too bad after all. There are
some very interesting events taking place
in human evolution and one of them has
been mentioned before by Sriram is the
human dispersal out of Africa which may
have occurred, with the major wave, around
50,000 years ago. Humans when they left
Africa, they were still Neandertals living
in Western and Central Eurasia. And we
have generated genome sequences from
several Neandertals also ones of very high
quality and we could make inferences from
these genome sequences that show that
Neandertals are, as expected also by
morphological evidence, a sister group to
modern humans. So, they're different
evolutionary lineage, but we could also
see the analysis of these genomes, was
first time shown by Ed Green in 2010, that
there was actually admixture going on.
There was some contribution of the
Neandertal genome into modern humans and
we've seen more recently sort of a weak
signal also for the other way around so
that some Neandertals may have picked up
modern human DNA when they interacted. So
the analysis of genomes from the last
100,000 years has also brought us
Denisovans. They were discovered based on
just a few small fossils, a tiny finger
bone and a few teeth, that were found in
Denisova cave. Based on the analysis of
their genome, we could show that they are
indeed a sister group to Neandertals. They
are like the Eastern brothers or sisters
of Neandertals and they have contributed
also their DNA to modern humans. But
unlike Neandertals, not to all humans
outside of Africa but to humans in Eastern
Asia and mostly the highest proportion of
ancestry, of Denisovan ancestry, you'll
find in Oceania here which makes us
believe that Denisovans were once much
more widespread than just located in
Denisova cave. Now, the problem is, still
we are looking sort of at the tips of
these evolutionary branches. So we're
looking at the last sort of Denisovans,
the last Neandertals, sort of relatively
late modern humans and it would be
tremendously exciting to look further down
in the past and try to understand sort of
what are the genomes like of these
ancestors of the archaic ancestor. What
for me would be very exciting is to find
the genome of the last ancestor between
humans and the archaics. As I mentioned
before, chemical reactions make DNA break
down in very short pieces. So, if you want
to address that problem from a biochemical
perspective, what you have to do is you
have to go for this extremely short
fragments and hoping that you would find
some surviving DNA in this size range. The
question then is where are we currently in
doing this? And this is sort of a typical
fragment size distribution of DNA
sequences that we recover from fossils
from a few years ago from the world record
holder, the horse genome, the 700,000 year
old horse genome that was sequenced by a
group in Copenhagen. As you can see, the
DNA sequences coming from this horse are
indeed quite short, sort of centering on
about 70 base pairs. But even so, we
could, in principle, make use also of
sequences that are shorter than this, up
to maybe 30-35 base pairs. So, the
question is are these sequences lost in
sample preparation or is it that truly
there's no longer DNA preserved in these
bones? I, and several graduate students in
my group, have sort of intensely looked at
this over the past years and we've
basically gone through every step of the
sample preparation process in trying to
refine it so that we maximize the number
of molecules that we keep in each step and
that we also extract the shortest possible
DNA fragments. This starts, obviously,
with DNA extraction so it's a process of
isolating the DNA fragments from the bones
or teeth and purifying them so that they
can be used in downstream reactions.
There's a second very important process
involved in DNA sequencing these days
which is Library preparation. In this
process you attach short artificial pieces
of DNA to the ends of each DNA fragment
and these short adapters, so-called
adapters, can then be used to make
thousands of copies of each molecule and
then also to prime the sequencing reaction
and read the molecule out. As the last
step of this process, you're taking the
sequences coming out of the sequence and
trying to match them to a known reference
genome. In our case it's the Human
Reference genome which has been sequenced
to very high quality in 2001. Even this
process, actually, has some issues and
we're also working on optimizing the
bioinformatic algorithm that we use to
identify human-like sequences. Going
through all this in several cycles for
several years, we eventually sort of
determined a fragment size distribution in
ancient bones that looks more like this.
This is what I've shown you before. This
was the distribution of fragments from the
permafrost. This now is a typical fragment
size distribution that we see in most
bones from caves and temperate climate
zones. What you see indeed are very very
short fragments in the bones. Many
fragments much shorter than we can
currently use for analysis because
sequences are so short you can't even
identify it as a human sequence anymore.
But it's not that we're sort of losing
these long ones and gaining the short
molecules Indeed, it's a sort of extra
gain of short molecules. These small black
stripes are the fragment size distribution
that I've shown you before. Sort of this
gain of short molecules is on top of this.
From the methods perspective, we're all
ready to sequence older DNA than before,
but the problem, of course, still is you
also need a site that allows an
extraordinary level of DNA preservation.
We were lucky enough to identify this site
in Northern Spain. The site is called the
Sima de los Huesos, the Pit of Bones. It
carries the remains of at least 28
virtually complete hominin skeletons that
were dated to 430,000 years ago. This is
the biggest assemblage of fossils from the
middle Pleistocene in Eurasia, the time
period preceding 130,000 years. The site
is very special in that it's 30 meters
below ground. It's very difficult to reach
it, it's only through a very hidden cave
entrance and you have to sort of crawl in
there. So, there's very little air
exchange with outside and very stable
temperature in the cave, around 11
degrees. This basically makes it a perfect
fridge. We were indeed successful in
recovering DNA fragments from several
fossils from this site. In blue here, I'm
showing sort of the part of the size
distribution we find evidence for the
presence of short, highly damaged, ancient
DNA molecules. The rest of this
distribution is mostly made up by
microbial sequences and modern human
contamination. The problem is there are
very few sequences only coming out. We had
to, in order to make some sense out of
them, we first had to look at one
particular type of DNA, a mammalian cell
which is mitochondrial DNA. This DNA is
special in that it's not present in only
two copies per cell, as the 23 chromosomes
that everyone knows about, but it's indeed
present in several copies in hundreds of
mitochondria. So for each part of the
nuclear genome, you have hundreds of
copies of the mitochondrial genome. Even
so, we still needed around two grams of
material, which is a lot with current day
standards. To just get one, sort of, nice
assembly of the mitochondrial genome. And
if you want to compare this to what we
typically get from late Pleistocene sites
from moderately preserved Neandertal
remains, there we get much more, many
more, copies of the mitochondrial genome
from much less material. In summary, it's
about 1,000 times less than what we've
seen in other Neandertal samples. Having
the mitochondrial genome, we could build a
tree from mitochondrial DNA. And the first
thing to note here is that if you look
just at the size of the branches, you will
see that all of these lineages here,
modern humans, Neandertals, Denisovans,
they're relatively long and the Sima de
los Huesos sequences on a short branch
indicate an extraordinary age. While the
other individuals kept mutating, this
individual died few hundred thousand years
earlier and thus less mutations. Further
than this, the tree is actually very
confusing and this is because
mitochondrial DNA, even though it is
preferable for technical reasons, only
shows a very limited, gives very limited
information about the ancestry. It's only
inherited from mothers to their children
and it reflects only a small part of the
population history. So instead of looking
at mitochondrial DNA, it's much better to
look at nuclear DNA to determine how this
individual was related to Denisovans and
Neandertals. After screening more samples
from this site, we were eventually able to
recover as much as 1,000 of the genome of
an individual from Sima de los Huesos.
There's extremely little data, but still
it's enough to do a very simple analysis.
Having so few sequences, one thing you
cannot do is actually compare these
sequences to a high quality reference
genome and then ask where does it differ.
You see these red dots here which indicate
sequencing errors because on average 1 in
100 base pairs is wrong. What you can do
instead is use a trick and use the data,
the reference data set of high quality
genomes including the genomes of many
present day humans, but also the archaic
genomes that we have sequenced to high
quality and identify positions in the
genome where, for example, the Neandertal
differs from all the other humans, where
the Denisovans differ from the
Neandertals, humans, and the chimpanzee,
and so on. You can then just count
positions overlapping these sites how does
the Sima do los Huesos sequence look like.
We did identify 100 sequences that overlap
sites that are sort of diagnostic for
Neandertals; and 42 of them actually
showed the Neandertal state. In contrast
to this we had a sort of roughly equal
number of sequences matching a Denisovan
specific site but only 10 shared the
Denisovan state. This is a highly
significant difference, and there's a very
simple inference from this is that indeed,
the Sima de los Huesos hominins were
closer to Neandertals than Denisovans
which also means, that Neandertals and
Denisovans must have diverged by the time
these individuals lived. One sort of
important message from this is that it
gives us for the first time, a relatively
stable anchor point in the timeline of
human evolution. Both the geological
dating methods as well as sort of the
branch lengths of the mitochondrial DNA
that we've looked at arrive at an age
estimate of about 400,000 years. So we can
say that the common ancestor of these two
archaic lineages must have lived before.
There have been in the past a number of
attempts to infer the population split
times using the genomes of Neandertals and
Denisovans and depending on the parameters
that you use you arrive at different ages.
If I use the most compatible estimates,
the estimates that are most compatible
with this number, then indeed I would
estimate that the human archaic diversion
is something like 550 to 7-800,000 years
ago and probably even towards the higher
end of this. The good, or the bad news,
is, as you will, that if you want to
sequence the common ancestor between
humans and Neandertals, we have to go much
farther back in time. There's still
challenges waiting for us here and I'm
looking forward to hopefully being able to
present this at some point. I want to
thank all my colleagues in Leipzig,
especially Svante Pääbo who's sort of the
mastermind behind all the ancient DNA work
in Leipzig; the Max Planck Society for the
very good funding that we have; and all
the colleagues in my lab and the graduate
students as well as, importantly, our
collaborators in Spain who've done
brilliant work in excavating these samples
very cleanly, I must say. Thank you for
your attention.
♪ [music] ♪